okay i guess it's three o'clock
let's let's get started so welcome back
this is the the second part uh logically
um at least um of of the two o of talks
um
for today so you know the first one
isn't the
prerequisite for for the second one but
you know they both kind of tell
tell a story so in the first one we
looked at the current security best
practices and
for this one we want to look more into
the
you know the future maybe
um to see what what else is out there um
some of the new techniques uh some of
the coming soon techniques to to make
oauth more
more secure okay so this time i'm i'm
better prepared
actually um the the slide decks is
already uploaded to to speakerdeck.com
privilege i just posted a link to the
slack channel as well
so you can get both slide decks right
now um
oh yeah and if you have any questions
you know at the end um
i'm you know i'm we can do a q a with
audio and video if you want to or just
audio
um or if you have any questions you want
to cue
at some point just put them into the
slack channel and i will i will get to
them
okay cool so um for those who haven't
been um
present for the first part this uh this
this this talk and the material and so
on is all part of a
um a bigger effort around uh um
you know like a high security over
profile so
multiple industries have started taking
the original oauth and
added additional specs to it additional
you know constraints or
um profiles as they call them to make it
more secure for you know for
for certain situations so one is the
most common or the most popular one
definitely is the um
the financial space uh psd2 the payment
service directive too
uh is based on on oauth and openly
connect for doing um you know
um payment uh initiation and and things
like that
so the the frp working group at the open
muddy foundation
um created uh a more secure
profile for oauth and old money connect
now i am
myself involved in a similar work for
the norwegian
health net um same idea right that we
are applying over an operating connect
for the health care sector
and certain requirements
because we need more security than what
you can find in the plane
specs um and similar things are
happening in the states with the
enterprise mission tailored off profile
so yeah so um
hopefully we will be able to converge
them um
there is some work going on in this
thing called sap2 which
will be more like a general purpose high
security over thing
not tailored specifically to the
financial api market
um but yeah but you know the
the ideas are all the same and um
i'm gonna show you a couple of those
things now okay
so that is but you know these two talks
i did are basically excerpts of of uh
of a full day training i'm doing right
now um but
obviously that's too much content yeah
so basically um i'm
i basically took that that um that
training material and
turn it into a little bit more like a 60
minute chunk
i guess so um we're gonna start with
basically what's the difference between
over 2.0 and 2.1
and then we're gonna look at the next
steps uh basically
the three big things i guess that are
actionable
today um is improving front channel
security
improving back channel security and
approved possession
access tokens okay so in my first talk
this morning
i looked at the various what they call
bcps best current practices
and there are a couple of them out there
you know the threat model uh
json web token bcp web apps
native apps and so on so
the question is now what is o of 2.1
so basically you can think of of 2.1 as
basically all of these documents
together um
become one new baseline
of specification called o of 2.1
and i mentioned these things
earlier but i want to basically point
out the most important changes between
2.0 and 2.1
and that is that the implicit grant is
gone the password grant
is gone when you're using authorization
code grant you must use
pixi to protect yourself against code
injection and cross-site request forgery
and other
types of leakage attacks of the
authorization code
there are strict requirements for how to
validate the redirect uris we've seen
many attacks around
redirect uri validation or flawed
validation rather
so redirect your eyes must be compared
as exact strings
no no
you know variables or you know
uh regular expressions things like that
which which you know
it's very hard to validate urls um
refresh tokens um we basically you know
since the since the implicit crime
is gone um there are actually
public clients that can legally from a
protocol point of view
use refresh tokens i mean that is uh
there are certain risks attached to that
so
um there's a pretty simple statement
here if you are a confidential client
you must use a client secret to send a
constrained refresh tokens
if you are a public line and want to use
them then you should use
refresh token rotation meaning you
should only use the refresh token once
and then the next time you get a new
refresh token
this allows you to detect replay attacks
and this also allows you to act on these
replay attacks by for example revoking
the refresh token automatically
if you think that is uh malicious right
and the last thing is a it's a small one
but basically uh oauth
or rather rfc 6750 allowed
um to send better tokens over a query
string that is not allowed anymore
you must either use the authorization
header
and or the post body
okay so that's our starting point and
now we want to look at additional
specifications that sit on top of ovals
um to improve the security so the first
part the first
complex will be around front channel um
improvement so you know uh basically a
typical overall overflow
for an interactive application consists
of two channels
one we call the front channel which is
over the browser yeah where the
the interactive ui happens and then this
returns an authorization code and then
the back channel takes over where the
client opens a back channel
communication to turn that code
into tokens so it turns out um the
front channel is the most vulnerable one
because it happens in the browser it
happens on
the user's machine right and um
that's why you know like modifying urls
or even
you know leaking data from there is is a
concern
okay um so let me introduce you to raja
and par yeah which i not a reggae band
or something
that there are three three independent
specs that uh
target in hardening the front channel
in oauth so let's start with raw
so um
ra stands for rich authorization
requests and
um the reason it exists is that more and
more
o of uh
protocols or specifications um have the
need of
um transmitting structured data
from the client to the authorization
server for example
in the in the banking industry where you
know like you wanna
make the user consent to a banking
transaction
like basically uh do you allow sending
50 euros to the pizza show
things like that um this is around
transaction ids
or um there's another speck in the
healthcare world which is called smart
on fire
that for example says do you want to
allow this client to reach the
the electronic health record of patient
five okay but only patient five even if
the user
the doctor has access to more patients
we want to only allow that client to get
access to this single
single patient right and um
since oauth itself does not have a
concept of
structured scopes many people just came
up with their own little format yeah for
example here
um something like uh scope colon
parameter right transaction colon id or
patient
colon something okay so um this is
you know i mean the the original of spec
does not mandate any format here
but you know most implementations just
say okay
there were some scopes and there is no
no features built in for um
for parameterizing those scopes yeah so
i can show you for example um
in the latest version of identity server
how how we implemented this requirement
right
so basically here is um a scope called
transaction and now um the idea is that
a client can now
basically ask for a scope called
transaction colon
one two three this scope does is not
registered right you're the only thing
you want to register
with that scope is the the base name and
then at run time
that thing that comes after the dot
should become the
you know the variable part if you like
so um we have introduced a new feature
in identity server for example
that is called um a resource validator
and here you can basically at runtime
look at the scope values and see
is does the scope have a format that you
know
right then it allows you basically to
pass that scope name and then you know
take it apart basically that's the name
of the scope and that is the variable
part and then you have the variable
available to the rest of the pipeline
okay
so um actually let's um
let's run this and then um
when you have a client then that asks
for such
a scope um let's see here
um so he has a client that asks for a
scope transaction colon
one two three then basically at runtime
we know okay the scope is actually
transaction but there's a variable part
to that yeah
um and then you can basically you know
cram such a scope or even derive other
claims from that scope
um but to be honest with you that is
really just a workaround
for the fact that oauth itself does not
have the concept
of uh structured scopes right i mean
this works for
many situations but
[Music]
it's not what rich authorization
requests are they go
much further so rich authorization
requests introduce a new parameter
called authorization detail
um and and that replaces the scope
parameter right
so maybe you want to say like allow the
client to make a payment of 45 euros or
allow the client to read a folder and
write a file things like that yeah um
instead of coming up now with your own
arbitrary complex structured scope
string
um the rich authorization requests goes
basically further in the way of that
basically you are sending a structure
structured object
along with the authorized request which
has a schema
so it's strongly typed yeah it has the
concept of
the data type you want to access and
maybe even an identifier
for a specific data type right so maybe
you want to say like hey
allow this uh company to print
picture number one but only number one
they should not be able to
access picture two three and five on
your google drive or whatever
um and as i said instead of like coming
up with your own custom data format
they are basically saying yeah just use
a an object
so we can describe this uh properly
right
um that is um
another example yeah of another schema
which is
basically modeling file system
permissions right
so you know like have read access to
this style have right access to this
file
for example and then the idea is as i
said that this
this thing um replaces
the scope parameter and basically can be
used wherever else you would use the
scope parameter
okay so for example that is an example
of the authorized request
you know you have your normal parameters
here like response type and and so on
and then you have this thing called
authorization details here and that is
the encoded
json object that is the structured
scope okay and that obviously gives you
far more
expressiveness than you know like having
a little string that now
you know becomes uh ultimately complex
um also by introducing a schema this
allows authorization servers to look at
the schema and then
present a consent screen that is
optimized for that situation
instead of trying to come up with a
general consent screen that can show all
kinds of different things
you can say oh that's a payment uh
initiation
let's show them a consent screen that
like it says okay who is the initiator
what's the target account you know
what's the amount what's the currency
you know
all these things basically okay and then
if the you know um and same as the
scopes
if the user consents uh or um um
it is the decline is allowed to ask for
that
uh scope of access uh authorization
detail will get
embedded into the access token
this access token will flow to the api
and the api can then say okay
this you know in this case subject id
one two three
authorized client four five six to
transfer
45 euros from bank account a to bank
account b
okay so
so that's rich authorization requests
now you might uh
ask yourself huh um
this probably is a it is a bit of a
sensitive string right i mean uh
if you could modify that string you
could change maybe bank account
numbers and and amounts and so on and
maybe
there is no consent or consent did the
user
you know consents by accident things
like that
so it would be nice to be able to
protect the data i mean generally
speaking
it would be nice in oauth that to
protect the whole authorization request
right
um because as i said there is potential
for
for misuse here and that is another spec
that is
uh almost done it's like in the last
stages of being finalized
it's called the shot secured
authorization requests
spec or char as many say and the idea is
really um
as i just said um instead of passing
unprotected query string claim you know
a
name value pairs over the authorized
request
you sign the query string okay and and
the easiest way to sign a piece of data
these days is basically by wrapping it
into a json object
signing that json object and that is
called a json web token yeah
which means an attacker could not
change the values of the parameters
after the after
the the chart has been created you can
which is pretty cool
uh authenticate the client already on
the front channel and don't have to wait
until the back channel
um and if you know if confidentiality is
is a thing
then you can also encrypt these tokens
if you want and then you know
um basically uh avoid a whole class of
attacks that deal with
leaking data rewriting urls or mixed up
attacks
things like this so the way this works
is
basically imagine that is your your
your authorization request and then
basically instead of
transmitting this to the token service
you are
transmitting this okay so the only two
parameters that are
left here is the client id which is
mandatory still
and then everything else is replaced
with this parameter called request
and this here is a json web token okay
so if we look inside the json web token
you see
that's how it looks like it basically
has
the the things that used to be on the
query string has
is now key value pairs inside
the json web token and that is pretty
cool yeah as i said it's it's not hard
to implement this it
it gives you nice security properties
here
and again if you want to see an example
of how that's implemented so in identity
server
you know all you need to do basically is
you associate
um an asymmetric key with the with the
client
and we'll see later on when we talk
about client authentication that the
same key
can be reused also for the back channel
authentication bit
and then um that's it right so once you
have that key associated
the uh in this case identity server is
able to
validate the incoming job token turn it
back into
you know an authorized request and just
use it
and if you even want to force the client
to use this new
technique because it's more secure then
you can say require request object
and then for this particular client
identifier will not accept anymore
uh and not a non-signed
authorized request okay so i can show
you that
uh basically um
uh that is running already so here's the
config
um let's have a look at my um
char client it's here that's pretty much
what you just saw on the slides
here's that client here's the json web
key that is an rsa
um public key i require the usage of
signatures
and the rest is just you know normal
normal business
and when i run this
here's an mvc client
and when i add you know open the network
trace and say
you know login you can see that
basically
here's my authorized request going from
the mbc client
to the server and you can see that
basically all parameters
have been replaced by this one request
parameter
the only parameter that is present is
the client id and
and that's an unfortunate uh
problem in nbc i cannot remove the
redirect uri
because mvc needs that internally um but
it's being ignored
because everything that's inside the
chart takes precedence over what's
outside the chart and since the redirect
uri is inside the chart
it will be overwritten basically by um
you know or even to be honest even
if there would be a mismatch between the
two what's inside what's outside
in the case of identity server we would
actually throw an exception
okay so that's cool um that makes your
authorized request much more secure so i
can log in just as normal you know
everything else stays the same
um if you are interested in how that
works in asp.net core
it's actually pretty cool that it's
possible to do that without
microsoft you know when they created the
feature didn't know about that
this will be a thing some someday yeah
um so um let's
get rid of that um you basically see
that you can in the openly connect hand
like an expert core you can plug in into
the various events
that are getting emitted yeah and the
one that we are particularly interested
in
is the event that gets
fired before we go to the authorization
server
yeah and when we go to our dc events
thing
you can see that there's an event called
redirect to identity provider
and then you see what i'm basically
doing is i'm taking the protocol message
from the context
i'm signing it that's what this is doing
that gives me this json that object
json web token that contains the
parameters
then i'm removing all the parameters
from the request i i set back client id
i have to set back redirect uri and i'm
adding the rest
as this additional parameter and that's
that's all you have to do and then
you're running on signed authorized
requests which is
pretty cool okay
so that's char um
one concern with char right so one leads
to the other
if we have a look back here is is that
this becomes a pretty long
url okay so if you imagine now your char
contains
a raw right the authorization details
this
json web token will get bigger and
bigger and this might be a problem for
certain browsers
especially on mobile devices
and um might be also a performance thing
uh maybe the client does not have the
crypto libraries
to create that json web token i mean in
the dot net space
it's all pretty easy but what in other
you know places
um so the next
spec think of it as a a complementary
spec on top of
char is called power which is stands for
pushed
authorization requests and the idea is
is that instead
that the client creates the shot and
sends it over the
the front channel basically what the
client is doing it first opens the back
channel communication and pushes all
those parameters
what it wants to use over a back channel
um
back channel which means a we can
authenticate the client again
even before they open the front channel
yeah
and basically and and you'll see what
happens here is
is that what the client is doing it
pushes all those parameters
and then the authorization will store
these parameters for the client for a
limited amount of time
and it will return back to the client a
reference
to these pushed parameters which they
call a request uri
and you see that they say lucky and this
will be valid for for 90 seconds
so that's basically before even the
client opens the front channel it first
does the back channel communication and
if it's a confidential client
we can combine that with client
authentication
right you could even also push a request
object
basically not just plain text variables
but a json web token for example if you
need a signature for
more regulation purposes in banking for
example or healthcare
and then when the client has this thing
back all the client needs to transmit
over the front channel
is pretty much only the client id
and this new parameter called request
uri which then points to this
uh previously pushed authorization
parameters
and that's pretty neat i think right
because that makes the url super short
there's nothing anymore that can be
manipulated this is a random thing with
a lot of entropy that no one can
play around with um
and you know that is um
probably even easier to implement than
creating the json that token
on the on the client side okay
so that is uh from my point of view
the free the free big um
the three big uh new things coming
um for for the front channel um
rich authorization requests will take a
while until this will be finalized
that's a pretty new spec uh char
the the json web token authorization
requests
they um that one is pretty much done
and par is so simple as a spec
basically the the authorization server
creates this endpoint to receive
parameters gives back a
an identifier i'm expecting this to be
uh available as a finalized spec pretty
soon
it's definitely something we are working
on for the the
next version of identity server okay so
just to summarize that ra is a
replacement for the scope parameter char
allows
for signed and authenticated
authorization requests and if
if needed encrypted also another thing i
didn't mention explicitly is
if using the char approach you can also
transmit additional data over the front
channel
and since it's in that signed json web
token that data becomes
trusted from an authorization server
point of view and that might be
interesting if the client has to
transmit additional data
and power really is a refinement of char
if you like which provides a dedicated
endpoint to push the authorization
request data up front
and then it can be used over the front
channel
okay so that's that's the the front
channel improvement if you like
um the back channel is basically then
uh the thing that takes over once the
authorization code has been transmitted
um back to the client or if you are in a
in a non-interactive flow like client
credentials for example whenever the
client basically wants to
um request a token right so
um if it's a confidential client yeah
which you know for most cases it is
the client has to authenticate with the
authorization server and the most
prevalent
authentication method these days is
shared secrets basically right
i mean i i mentioned it this morning it
is easy to get started with right you
just have a string you share that string
and yeah it's work it's working yeah um
for everyone who deployed his
authentication method at a larger scale
knows that there are some challenges
right i mean
you need to store them somewhere
on the server side you want to store
them hash on the client side you need
them back in its original form so you
can't hash them
uh the configuration system must
distribute these things somehow
securely um
and um yeah so
long story short shared secrets are a
bit of a pain
because also you know how good is the
secret when it's shared
generally speaking the recommendation is
to get get away from shared secrets
um also you know like one one thing that
is a big concern is that
share secrets are getting transmitted
over the network yeah so
um you know i just had a customer last
week where
you know they have deployed software in
in the company or a hospital in their
case
and the the services they want to access
are
in the cloud right so even if they can
protect those secrets
effectively on the machines because they
control the hardware
and the the secrets travel over the
network right and um
since they are not controlling the
network infrastructure they are you know
they go over reverse proxies and so on
um you know that those secrets are
exposed yeah it would be nice to have
something
uh more robust and that basically is
secrets based on asymmetric keys okay so
the idea is simple instead of having a
shared secret or a symmetric key yeah
on both ends um the the authorization
tab only has the public key
the the client has the private key
which also means um the authorization
server does not have to store that
secret
in any special protection mode right
because it's not a secret it's a public
key
um the client yes the client needs to
store that secret securely
there's no way around that regardless
how you do it yeah
um and then because
you can then prove knowledge of that
private key
by using a signature instead of
transmitting the key
itself that secret is never exposed over
the wire so the whole
network leakage eavesdropping thing
concern is um is is not existing
um there are two ways of of you know
leveraging well there are many ways but
there are two official ways
of of leveraging um asymmetric keys
for for client authentication
um one is called private key chart and
it's more like an application level
solution where you are writing
explicitly code
to to to sign something and then use
that as an authentic authenticator
um the other one is using good old
mutual tls you know like
x509 certificates where the transport
channel takes care of the crypto um
and does you know allows that the client
proves he knows a certain secret of the
server and and vice versa
um and you can combine both methods
which we'll see is an interesting
technique
later in in the talk okay
let's have a look at private key chat
the private key chart
basically the idea is um instead of
um sending the shared secret over the
wire
what you what the client is doing
similar to the idea with
um with char like the signed authorized
requests
um the client creates the json web token
and signs it with the private key okay
and then um this is basically used as a
replacement for
the secret because now the client has a
piece of data that proves that he knows
the client key
that did a private key sorry um what's
inside of that json web token
well there are a couple of claims that
must be in there like the issuer claim
and the subject id claim they they
contain the client id of the oauth
client
the audience claim must point to the
token endpoint
of the authorization server jti is um
is a unique identifier like a guid for
example that allows
us to do replay detection which is
another nice feature of this
authentication method
since we can detect uh replayed
requests because the jti you would
you you would see it twice right and you
see oh so somebody used that token twice
um expiration man which is basically
um trimming down how long your replay
cache must be
and then issue that tells you how how
old the token is or when
when it was issued yeah so basically the
top of the client is now to basically
create such a json lab token and instead
of transmitting the client id client
secret
um the client basically sets a client
assertion
which is the json lab token and then
there's an an official
client assertion type okay
so um all the code that's necessary for
doing that is on the slide but i think
it's more exciting to show it to you
in a real example so again let's have a
look at the server configuration first
how would you
how would you um configure such a client
well and guess what
it is exactly the same as you would do
with the signed authorized request in
other words you can use the same
credential
now to do authentication on both the
front and the back channel
okay um there's another client which has
a little bit more options here there's
this guy so
you know in in identity server generally
speaking
you can leverage this using and and i
mentioned it earlier x509 certificates
yeah which
that is just an x59 third as its base64
form or a chasing that key and the json
lab key is a more
general purpose data structure because
you can format any type of key with that
um i mean you could even use symmetric
keys if if you want to but
i i wouldn't recommend it yeah i would
say stick with an asymmetric one use
rsa or elliptic curves okay
and that's it basically from an
identical point of view um
almost at least you plug in
the correct uh secret validator
and uh parser type in here
and then um basically what happens is
when you go to the
open idconnect provider and you go to
the discovery document
you will see that it has an
authentication method that it supports
where is it
[Music]
runtime response times response oh yeah
token endpoint authentication method and
it says
uh private key chart that tells you okay
this is
supported by the op money connect
provider so now that that's the server
setup and now let's have a look at the
private key chart
client side so that that's a console
sample here
um and the idea is pretty simple
um you are creating the json web token
that happens create here so you see that
basically here
we are creating a json web token using
the private key
here are the claims that must be in
there the client id the audience
the json web token id um
the issuance time the not before like
when is the token valid and when does it
expire right that creates a string
now which is basically your credential
yeah and then you can
request the token right and instead of
passing in a client id and the client
secret
we are passing in a client assertion as
they call it
the type of the assertion is a constant
which comes from the spec and that is
the json web token we just created
okay and that returns basically an
access token and from that point on you
just call your apis
um as normal okay so um
when i run this you know um here's my
private key chart console
so basically you see here um that's the
the token response coming from the
server
and you know it's just a normal token
just that for
accessing that token we haven't used a
shared secret
it's now using a private public key pair
and that's it
okay
oh yeah and the same i guess i should
show you the same for mvc
that is also um always a good exercise
to see how that would work
in a real application so
i will keep short here's my mvc
guy and i'm basically using the same
technique as before i'm i'm hooking in
those events
yeah um the oidc events and when we have
a look at that
you can see that microsoft kind of
prepared for the scenario where you
don't
use a shared secret they don't have a
built-in implementation for doing
you know like all of the token creation
and so on but when you are basically
hooking this event here authorization
code received that is happening
after you receive the authorization code
but before
you redeem the code and turn it back
into a token
you see that basically on this context
they are passing in here there's a token
endpoint request
then you can set the client assertion
type and the client assertion and then
this is used instead of a client
secret okay so actually when we look at
my startup here
you can see that um i haven't even you
know
there is no client secret configured
here because this is the json web token
that gets
um generated on the fly
okay so that is cool
as well um oh yeah and again i i should
mention since we are creating the json
depth token
we can add more content to it if we want
to right
additional claims that would flow to the
authorization server and maybe you want
to try
some custom logic um on that
you know on the fact that you have
additional data being transported
from the client to the to the token
endpoint
okay so here is all the code i just
showed you um
we don't need to do that again
cool um
so to be honest with you um um
that's that's you know that's what i
would do yeah i would
um i would go away from
pub from from shared secrets right
deploy
a public line key pair instead for my
clients
and then switch both on the front
channel and on the back channel
to signed you know uh artifacts right
on the front channel sign my authorized
request on the back channel
use the the the private key shot instead
of my
client secret you can use the same key
material yeah and that's great
and that basically um gives you
better security now that is only about
the client to token service
communication
another thing that is a you know a real
security concern is
um what happens if you're leaking the
access token right now now now we used
all of these new bells and whistles
to to to make the token request more
secure
but what if you are leaking or the the
token
right so once the attacker has
stolen a token uh it doesn't matter
anymore how secure your authentication
method was the token is gone and can be
used right that is the whole
crux of the the bearer token concept in
olaf that
there is no binding from the token
to the client that requested the token
in the first place
so if the client is leaking the token it
can be
used by an attacker to impersonate the
client or impersonate
the user okay um so
the opposite of bearer tokens is called
proof of procession
tokens right where basically you find a
way to cryptography
cryptographically bind the access token
to the owner
to the client and if an attacker would
now be able to steal that access token
um the attacker could not use the access
token because it's missing
the last secret so to speak to prove
that he
owns the token as well okay that is
to be honest with you not very easy to
accomplish i mean there are
there have been many many attempts to
solve the problem
um either you are you are introducing
heavy crypto
at the application level because
basically you need to
somehow bind that token to the client
and the client
now needs to prove to the api that he
knows the private key by signing the
http request for example
um this has been proven to work but
has never really gotten any traction
because it's it's pretty complicated and
also
there are some unsolved problems with
application level
um token binding like for example
streaming right i mean
um the whole signature thing requires
you to have a chunk of data
uh to be able to run a hash over that
but a stream of data
you know that's harder to do um
many people thought maybe the the
transport layer can save us and
there was a stack in the in the working
called um token binding
um but that never also never got really
a lot of traction so we were basically
back to square one and thought like
how can we introduce a disproved
possession semantics yeah so just to
summarize this
this is the real problem right you are
sending a token from the client to the
api
an attacker is able to steal that token
somehow
yeah the attacker can replay the token
and and impersonate the decline
so um after many years of trying to find
solutions we we are we are basically
coming back to
uh technology which has been around for
many many years and it's called mutual
tls
yeah um or some people call it client
certificates
yeah for for tls so you know that um
[Music]
normally when you do https yeah what
you're doing is
you are authenticating the server right
so you know many people think tls is all
about
encryption and stuff well it does
encryption as well
but first and foremost that the the
biggest benefit of tls is
is that it authenticates the server
right because
um you know before you send confidential
stuff to the server you want to know
you're in the right place
ma'am there's an extension to tls
for client side authentication which is
not used that often because historically
there have been
problems with that and when people hear
mutual tls they think of pki
and cas and so on but to be honest with
you it's gotten
there's a renaissance around mutual tls
it's gotten easier to use
um and maybe you maybe you don't need
all that pki stuff as i'll show you in a
second right
so if you employ
certificates on both ends of the tls
tunnel you can authenticate both sides
okay and in essence what that means is
is that both sides can prove they know
a certain private well they they both
sides can prove they know
a secret okay and once both sides are
happy with the other one saying
i know the secret and that's how i prove
it to you and that's very complicated
yeah in reality
we can be very sure that you know
we know the identity of each other now
with that level of approval what the
token service can do
actually is is embed inside
the access token um an identifier
that represents the secret that the
client has
proven to know during the token request
okay so in other words um
only this particular client here
can prove that he knows a secret and the
secret identifier is what we call
a thumb or and you know which is
technically
the hash of the public portion of the
x509 certificate in this case with
sha256 so that's why it's called x5gs256
and the special claim for that is called
the cnf claim it's the confirmation
claim
so in other words this cnf claim binds
the access token to the client okay
cool so now how does that work i mean
how do we make it work so what about
this what if um
you know a client when it starts up just
creates a public private key pair
an x 509 certificate basically and then
uses that x59 certificate
to to basically
start the tls handshake with the token
service
right now the token service would embed
that some print in there
and then the client would use the same
certificate to open the tls channel to
the api
now the api once the tls handshake is
done successfully
he will also see on the tls channel
this value here so all the client now
needs to do is
is compare the value he got from the tls
channel
with the value that's inside the access
token and if they match
he knows that this is actually the
client that asked for the token in the
first place
or in other words the client proved
possession okay sounds complicated
yeah well security is hard right but
but it's not undoable right so the good
news is
starting with net core two point
something
we can actually encode create x 509
certificates
on the fly okay that's all the code you
need and you know
there are some magic things in there
that don't you know whatever it works
yeah what this creates or
yeah does is it generates me an x 509
certificate
on the fly that i can use um for opening
a tls channel
and for opening the tls channel all you
need to do is you
assign that certificate that we just
created
to the handler that you use to open your
http
client okay and then
basically all you need to do is request
the token
create the hp client assign
the certificate to it and then do your
token request
okay and from that point on that
certificate will be used
to to um you know to to
authenticate in quote-unquote the client
um and that can be used then for the uh
by the token server to um to embed this
um this uh thumbprint into the access
token
yeah this this certificate is not
usefully for authentication right
it's just an additional secret that the
client provides that allows the token
service to bind
the token to that secret yeah and as
long as the attacker does not know that
additional secret
it cannot use the token because and
since the secret never went over the
wire just the public key part
that's how that works okay so let me
just show you first
how this works in action and then we can
have a look at some
considerations around it okay so here's
my
um let's see where is my
mtls guy
so here you see here we are
generating the certificate and then we
are requesting the token
and then you know i will just output
the token on the screen so let's do that
and then you'll see that the token will
contain this thumb print
okay so here you see that's the
resulting access token and here's an
additional claim now and that's exactly
the thumbprint okay so now basically
what i what i need to do is
in my api um
in my api
i've written an additional middleware
and what this middleware is doing
basically is it
does does exactly what i what i
mentioned earlier it it gets
the client certificate from the
transport channel
it gets the thumbprint for that
certificate which is basically the
basics before url
version of the sha256
hash of the certificate right
and then it extracts the value of this
x5t
claim from the json web token and if
they match
all is good if they don't match then
well
you know we reject the request and that
means
um and that means that
that the client has not proven to know
that secret okay
so that's how that works um now
setting up mutual tls is a bit more
involved yeah i
i mean i i i totally have to admit that
yeah
but you only have to have to do that
once yeah so first of all you have to
think about
um basically um it doesn't work really
well
um to to share both
non-mutual tls and mutual tls
um endpoints uh on the same connection
right so iis done does that historically
uh with uh dedicated paths here
that is not going forward with http 2
and beyond
um so basically what you have to do is
separate them maybe on the domain name
so it could be a separate domain name
could be a sub domain
for example yeah that's my preferred
version yeah i'm putting them on the sub
domain
and regardless which method you're
choosing when you look at the
metadata of your token service
there will be a new element called mtls
endpoint aliases
and that basically says okay if you're
looking for the mtls version of the
token endpoint
that is the one to look for and not the
other one
okay so
once you have that you have to deploy
this somewhere
or host it um i i had a look at a couple
of
web server choices um and you know iis
as i said does only path based azure
does path-based as well but
in a weird way kestrel does well castrol
does not support the isolation out of
the box they are working on that for the
next version
the one that i had the best results with
is nginx to be honest
that is super super flexible how to host
your endpoints and
the tls settings and so on um and i'm
pretty sure there are other other
options here as well
but if you're using nginx basically the
idea is pretty simple
you host your application here on your
normal domain
right and that's all of the headers
you're passing through so when a request
comes in
um you are forwarding that to the
internal
server you know your localhost 5000
whatever
and then you're setting up a separate
server here which is the the sub domain
which does mtls
and then you said okay i i want mtls
here
and then you can you know have some
options about do i require pki or not
i didn't require that and then basically
you're telling nginx to forward the tls
certificate
as a header to asp.net core
okay um and then
on the asp.net core side you need to
turn that header back
into an x59 certificate there's a
built-in middleware for that it's the
certificate forwarding middleware and
you basically have to
tell that middleware how to turn
that header back into an x509
certificate in the case of nginx
you basically um url
decode the header and that basically is
the byte array and that is your x5493 so
that's
easy enough and then you wire up support
for x509
and again that this is all built in it's
nothing that i
added to action core it is um
it is all um you know built in since
version 3.0
and then the last thing i did was i
actually enabled mutual tls
on identity server and that is
how i uh how i uh you know validate that
that and then can embed the cnf claim
into the access token okay um that is uh
how i did it at the api i showed you
that already that that's my
my um my validation
um middleware so just to prove that it
works
let's actually um run the api as well
okay so here's my api um
and here is my
[Music]
client
so that is now my token request when i
hit enter i call my api so the api was
happy with my token which means that
it was able to match the thumbprint okay
uh oh yeah very last thing maybe to show
you how that works in spirit core
uh as a client yeah um so there is
uh an mtls
mvc app so that is a bit of a funny
story
so microsoft
has half of half of the support uh we
need
man um so first of all i'm making use of
the fact that in
in action core in the openly connect
handler you
can replace the back channel http client
basically all i'm doing here really is
i'm replacing the http client and i'm
i'm inserting my my certificate okay
the other complication you will run into
is that they don't know anything about
these mtls endpoint aliases yeah so you
have to tell them to use different
endpoints when they are opening
the the back channel yeah i've i haven't
found a good way of doing that um
besides replacing their complete open
money connect discovery document
plumbing
man which sounds worse than it is
um basically what i was able to do is i
i wrote my own
i configuration manager i i'm using
internally that's the standard one they
have
yeah and then basically whenever they
want to get my configuration i'm first
calling the built-in configuration
manager and then i'm fixing up
on the fly the endpoint urls for the
token endpoint and in this case also for
the revocation endpoint
then from an from an asp.net core point
of view you know they don't know about
this they're using mtls
and it and it works okay so
um you can tell that hp and core was not
written for many of these advanced
features in mind but
i think it's a good sign that the
extensibility model
that they have allows you to do all the
things okay without you know
major surgery i guess to the
framework okay um
so that's that's it yeah um obviously
there's more there's more to learn here
but these are the
you know my my main key takeaways yeah
the
secure the front channel um use
asymmetric keys
yeah use the private key shot mechanism
for the back channel
and then you can if if if you are
interested in this proof of procession
feature
you can layer on top tls client
certificates
yeah um you don't need a ca for that
you don't need a pki for that you can
just generate them yourself
the client the client doesn't even need
to be a confidential client yeah i mean
imagine uh i think where this is a
really compelling feature it is for
native mobile applications right because
these are the types of applications
which are typically exposed to
untrusted networks yeah and if this mute
you know
your your mobile app generates this
session certificate
when it asks for the token then it can
you know
use the access token and even if the
token gets leaked over you know
um maybe the maybe this this app at
this access point at the airport called
free wi-fi is not as secure as you think
right
um so even if if that token gets leaked
over there
the attacker cannot use it because it is
missing the private key of the session
certificate
so i think that is without too much
effort a way to
tremendously increase the security of
your own deployment
okay so that's it from my point of view
um if you have any questions please
speak up uh now with audio otherwise put
them into the slack channel
and i will get to them or maybe i will
get to them
right now um so
there's one question do you generate the
mtls certificate for each client for
each request or something else
basically um it is for each token
request
well it depends right so um
it's a so-called session certificate
right and
you define what that means what a
session is for you maybe it is per
application startup
maybe you do it per token request right
um the point is you have to use the same
tls certificate for both the request to
the token service and the request to the
api
so they logically belong together
right um but besides that um
you know you can mix and match any way
you want the next question is
um the next question is how about load
balance clients
do they need to synchronize mg lessons
no they don't right
um that's the nice thing about it yeah
it's just an additional
an additional key that you are
transmitting alongside the token request
there is no registration for that
necessary nothing it's just
imagine you're doing a normal token
request but provide an additional secret
that the token service can bind
to to the token that's
that's about it